Oh wait, you're listening.
You are listening to radio
lab radio from W N y.
S. C e. Yep.
Are you surprised that this is so popular?
Am I surprised? You know what I'm
surprised about? I'm surprised that,
um, this morning I was walking to
the subway and I was like, man,
I want to listen to my k-pop playlist.
Yeah.
I guess I'm a little
surprised with that myself
taking notes.
Robert [inaudible] fantastic.
And I did listen to it and it
was amazing and I, it's just,
it's undeniable.
Okay. I'm Jad Abumrad I'm Robert Krulwich,
Radiolab [inaudible] oh, sorry. No,
no, you go, no, no, no. Like today,
a story from a reporter,
Alex Young. Hi. Hi.
We're just to set it up.
This story for us connects to one we did
a few podcasts ago about Gary Hart and
the moment when,
how we covered politics changed this
story is about a similar change that's
happening right now. Right in front of
our eyes in South Korea. So we're like,
we're going to travel a few thousand
miles. Yeah. And in this one,
all the usual dynamics you would expect
in this kind of story get totally
flipped. It's not about politics at
this time. It's about music fans. Yeah.
It's going to sound a little bit like
a music pieces you've already heard,
but really it's a puzzle.
If you really admire someone
and love them and so on.
How much do you want to know
about? About them? Really? Yeah.
Is it tell me everything
or tell me nothing.
And if someone does try and tell you
everything, at what point do you say, stop
you ready? I'm ready. Where do, where
do you, where should we begin? Well,
I think before we get to like the
moment that I am very excited about,
I need to kind of give you guys a little
bit of of the world in which all of
this is going to happen. Okay. And so
we're going to start with this woman.
When I tell my friends about it,
I kind of describe it as a prison,
but it's a prison you
decide to walk into. Okay.
So this, this is Sarah Wolfgang. Um,
I was a former trainee for
Kate pop group in Korea. Um,
and I'm here to talk about
that. Sara is Korean American.
She was born in America, but I
actually grew up in Korea. Um,
my parents both worked for the military.
And you were living in soul? Correct.
Okay. Yongsan Seoul and Sarah says
that her whole k-pop adventure,
it all started with her because
when she was growing up,
I really never liked school,
so my parents were kind of
wanting me to do something else.
I think they still wanted me to finish
school, but they encouraged her to
try out acting, to go to auditions,
try out for school plays. And when I
was in high school, about 15 years old,
maybe 10th grade at her head shots ended
up getting passed to a South Korean
record company. And when we received
the phone call, they were like, oh, hey,
you want to come in and audition
for a k pop group? And I was, uh,
I actually denied it. I really
didn't want to do it. Oh.
But then she thought maybe this
will lead to an acting job.
So I went in and then they're like, okay,
they put me in front of a camera
and there they asked me to um,
sing and I'm not the best singer,
but that doesn't really
matter to K-pop. Nope.
Everything you know can be touched up
really well. To make a long story short,
they ended up offering her a contract
of more than five years and as part of
that contract, we were asked
to move into the dorms.
[inaudible]
there are these facilities that all of
the agencies have for further idols and
training. They described
it like a boarding school.
All the kids kind of live together and
so I moved to the dorms with six or seven
other girls and it was here that Sarah
says the company basically kept them
under lock and key. Well,
they didn't lock us in there,
but we weren't allowed to leave.
It's like one of those cockroach prisons
or like those ant prisons you can walk
in but you can't walk out. Why is
she doing this again? Well thank you.
[inaudible]
let me explain to you guys just
like how phenomenally huge k-pop is.
K-Pop actually started in
Korea in the early nineties,
but like in the last five or so years,
it is just
build out into the rest of the world.
And by some estimates it was generating
like around $5 billion a year.
And then if you throw in like
k drama, k soap operas, um,
which is called the, how you wave that,
how you wave in 2012 was
valued at $83 billion.
Jesus. Yeah. And nearly all of this,
it's based on a kind of fantasy
because k pop stars are, you know,
products of fantasy world.
That's Professor Souk Young Kim Theater
Studies at University of California,
Santa Barbara. I studied
k-pop industry. You know,
f stars are the embodied forms of Manga
and enema and all these unrealistic
figures that don't exist in real life.
So they have to have
really beautiful face,
beautiful body, you know,
excessively long legs, broad eyes,
pale skin flowing hair. They are
not the creature of this world.
They shouldn't be, you know, they own,
they can only exist in fantasy world
in that fantasy. That's
what trying to manufacture
in those dorms, like they
wanted us to lose weight. Um,
so we would wake up at like four or 5:00
AM in the morning and then go hiking.
Sarah says after the hike
they'd come back eat breakfast,
which usually consisted of lettuce,
then they'd have dance classes,
singing classes, and
then we have lessons of,
I think they're called like humble lessons
where basically this guy would show
up to the dorm and he would
teach us to bow correctly.
So like we would have
to bow in unison. Um,
so that we seem to as
like one big happy group,
they weren't allowed to have
cell phones, no computers, nope.
Or a relationship of any kind.
All companies pretty much don't want you
to be in a relationship. And in fact,
one of the girl too can
told me that in 2011,
the, one of the members of 21,
which is like a whole group
managed by YJ Entertainment,
revealed that their management said
they should not be dating before age 29.
What? Oh my God,
they shouldn't be dating because stars
belong to the public. To the fence
and
that was a thing. It was like a
purity thing. No, that period.
Angelic Virgin Madonna image. This
by the way, is k-pop writer, a g park
editor@largeatsoompi.com like girl groups.
These are calling like nations fairies.
You know, they had this pure Chast um,
image to them and the boy bands too,
because that being single makes
them more marketable and appealing.
And Adrian says that's, that's
the main takeaway. Of course,
there's all kinds of cultural
observations that you can make about this,
but the main driver here is economic.
The founders of K-pop knew back in the
early nineties that the fans would love
the starves even more if the stars
weren't just beautiful and perfect,
but they also seemed somehow available.
You would be surprised how many
k-pop stars come out and be like, oh,
I've never had my first kiss yet. And
they're like 1920 years old. Kind of like,
I have it on my first kiss.
Will it be with you? You know,
in feeding the fantasy
kind of thing. Way, way.
Is that all that different
than America? I mean,
didn't you feel weirder or
stranger or something or when,
what's when like, I don't know,
Catherine Zeta Jones married that guy.
Whatever his name is. Yeah. I don't really
wanna think about his name cause it,
it changed things for me. Me
Too. I didn't have that feeling.
I mean I would come on you. Oh, you're
always going on about Meryl Streep.
She married by the way to
me. But no, she doesn't know.
She is married to a chill, very
quiet man is a sculptor, you know?
How does that make you
feel? I look around.
It just shows to see like what does he
got through? I don't have no with that.
My point is, is it that
diff? I mean America,
the American celebrity culture has
fantasy woven into of course yet,
but there's a big difference
in Korea, that fantasy world.
It is so extremely controlled,
way more than in America
according to Sooki on camp.
And it's controlled not
just by the agencies,
by the fence to the extent that
it defies all of our common sense.
What do you mean? I'll
give you an example.
This one I heard from professor CQ and
Kim and also writer Leslie. Tim Bucko.
I'm the editor in chief of soul beats.
It's a big k pop k entertainment site.
Okay.
2008 there was this new girl group,
girls generation halls, girls generation,
girls generation is a nine member.
All Girls Group. That was like
hearing on like music shows and like
variety shows being promoted as like
the girl next door.
I'll cute and you know like the ideal
girlfriend kind of idea unless he says
that on some of these shows girls
generation would appear with boy bands,
you know, who were also
promoting at the same time.
Groups such as super junior ss five oh one
and devious k. Okay.
So these three groups in various shows,
they would be like standing
next to each other on stage
talking to each other
during variety shows.
And this is where we kind of
get into the cultural stuff.
There are several times when
they're onstage with one
or more of these boy bands
and they're kind of taking the microphone
from the host or whatever and kind of
just nodding their head. Whereas the boy
bands are like doing these deep Babs,
some of the fans are seeing
this and they're thinking
that's disrespectful. Why?
Why would that be disrespectful? Well,
the thinking is that since
girls generation is a new group,
they should be bound much more
deeply than their soon bays or their,
their seniors being, um,
a rookie group is a big deal in Korea
because seniority is something that people
hold very strongly. And so as a rookie,
you have to show deference to the
superior, you know, senior groups,
they're not showing respect. They're not
showing deference just in the bowing.
That's how some of the fans were taking
it. But I mean, aside from all that,
and this is the key,
is that some of the fans thought that
the girl's generation girls were flirting
with some of the boy
bands, like, you know,
with these little side long glances or
teasing them. And so that interaction
[inaudible] seeing that fans were
very, very, very upset about that.
And so all the fans of the three groups,
the three boy bands got together
and decided to do a black ocean.
What is that?
Yeah. That we're going to get there.
Fast forward to June 7th, 2008,
all of those bands that were on those
TV shows are playing this big k-pop
concerts, this um, event
called Dream Concert,
a huge stadium show, like
more than 40,000 fans. And um,
the call souk young told me that there's
one thing you need to know about fans,
about k-pop fans at live
events. They all light sticks
and they come in different colors
cause each band has its own color.
Super Junior for example, has blue.
And when they appear on stage you see this
light sticks waving in support
of their stars on stage.
So they played for while.
And when ss five Oh one
comes out, a whole place just
turned to light.
Green show goes on TV
XQ comes to the stage.
They were like the biggest band
at the time. And then upload
thousands and thousands of
these ruby red literally lights.
And at some point girls'
generation takes the stage.
And here's the thing, pretty much
as soon as they walk on stage,
all the people in the audience
turn off their light sticks. [inaudible]
what? Suddenly there was black
out in the whole auditorium.
Everybody stops clapping,
screaming, silence.
Were you saying like the whole,
like everybody, 40,000 people? Yes.
And if you look at look up pictures
of it, it was a stadium performance.
The entire stadium was black. No
Way. Yes. Way. Look at this picture.
Oh my God.
[inaudible]
well I are we looking at
this? It's totally black.
It's like a whole football stadium. This
isn't photo-shopped or something. No.
Cause if you look down in the corner
you can kind of see the pink girls
generation section. Oh
yeah. There's a little,
there's like a list of pink
pink as their color. Yeah.
And then everything else is black girls
generation had to sing and dance to the
silent crowd.
Oh.
Has anything like this ever
happened before? Never. Well,
how on earth did they pull that off?
How could you get this many
people doing the same thing? Okay.
So the way that these shows happen,
at least at these dream concerts is that
different sections of the auditorium
belong to different fan groups. Oh. So
they sell it as Zeland seating. Right.
So the fan clubs actually get to
like dole out the tickets. Uh,
and during the show there's this moment
where some of the fan club leaders stood
up and held up these
signs that said, quiet
dude, this is that. This
is that upsetting. Yeah.
Do you understand about this robbery?
Like it doesn't seem like the most weed.
He soon I've ever heard a little blink
of an eye, a little leaning forward,
a little failured about, but that's
just the difference again. Okay.
Wait a second, if you, if you would
allow me to frame for a second. So yeah.
So what have we learned so far?
We've learned that this is a global
phenomenon mirror this well mate,
it's a global phenomenon.
Born of the nightmare of these stars
who seem to be tightly held in check by
everybody, the fans and the agencies.
Everybody. That's what we know.
So that's what we know. So, okay.
And this sort of tight control is how
it operated for quite a few decades.
But, and this is why
I wanted to do this whole story in the
first place just a couple years ago in
walks to this guy
and he just messes everything up.
Hey,
they are radio lab [inaudible]
yeah.
We sent an interpreter with a mic over
to the Gangnam district and sold. Oh,
they got numb style to speak with a guy
named Leon young Goo JPM but you know,
he told me to call him Mr.
Lee. Hello? Hello. Hey.
I hopped on the line from our studio
in New York when I got started. Yeah.
Are you guys ready? Yep.
Okay. So here's the story.
Bozo Tacome [inaudible] early 2002
y'all need to put through retirement.
Mr. Lee, he was working at a news
organization called sports soul,
which did all kinds of
things, not just sports.
They also did like business and
entertainment, dodgy. And then young
[inaudible].
He was actually in charge of all the
online news and while he was there,
I think it's fair to say that he
took his reporting very seriously.
Like he always had this
idea in his mind. Yeah.
One team, one [inaudible].
Who do I [inaudible]
I believe any contents that
can be published that's
possible to publish should
be freely published. That's the kind of
culture that would be better to have.
So he was a guy who believed
in an independent press,
but he also knew that there were certain
things that he just couldn't report on
how it looks out of your soul.
[inaudible] having gone that certain
subjects like politics. Oh, your mother.
We're just dangerous. We do.
How, how, why, what is it,
what you're talking about? We, we
actually need to back up a little bit.
Put this into a little bit of context.
So between like after the Korean war,
between say the 60s and the 80s, um,
South Korea was under a series
of military dictatorships.
And there was basically a
censorship of the press.
Things got a lot better in the 90s
when they turned to civilian rule.
But even today,
the government still has a branch
that goes around the Internet and,
and deletes websites, uh, for
their content. So this is the,
this is like the world in which the press
is living in a Brazilian [inaudible].
So getting back to Mr. Lee, it's 2010.
He's at sports soul having dreams of
independence and he feels like politics is
a little tricky.
So he does what to me feels like a
little bit of a Trojan horse moved.
Have you all day titled Basically he says
if I can't do independent reporting in
politics, I'll just sneak
it into celebrity news.
Uh, so [inaudible] [inaudible]
and so we looked on the Internet for um,
Hollywood news and media in the UK at
[inaudible] Hall and looked
at what they doing every
day. So he studied the sun, US weekly.
TMZ wait, he studied
TMC. That's what he said.
You know how they take their pictures?
How close do they get? Cause there isn't,
there wasn't Paparazzi in Korea and we
decided to apply that to South Korea.
So what,
what kind of tactics did you use to
get the photos in the first place?
She didn't publish it.
You can go on board.
We decided the best way to do the
reporting is, you know, by hiding it
a car, their first target where
these two stars, John Young,
who is an idol from a boy band called
shiny huge band and an actress,
her name is Shinsei Kyung,
TD Ritani is all,
first you have to go through the
information gathering process.
So they tailed both the stars on and off
for one month to get a sense of their
movement patterns, you
know, and they figure out,
they have this pattern of meeting up in
front of her apartment really early in
the morning, like three in the morning
or something. And they take [inaudible]
these walks.
So I've seen in TD detainees late October,
2010 it came to a point where we couldn't,
we couldn't miss the opportunity.
They call this, I guess they call this
the De de [inaudible] dating a date,
which I think is pretty funny.
And on this particular day,
one of Mr Lee's reporters,
steaks out the apartment and the two
stars meet up to take their walk.
Okay. And
you get the very first Paparazzi
photos as far as we know in Korea.
So these photos are, so what?
I think they're so cute.
It's these two idols, you
know, walking down the street,
hand in hand under these
yellow streetlights and they
just look like they're in
their own little world.
There's this one photo where he's pulling
back her hair and I think he's putting
like an earbud in her beer and
they're, maybe they're sharing a song.
They're listening to a song together.
Oh, he's got her purse on his shoulder.
You know, he's just
holding her bag for her.
What happens when the photographer
guy runs up and goes, well, the,
the guys at sports, so kind of
drew this line. They're like,
we're gonna keep back a
distance from the celebrities
coming through a car window. Right.
Do they see the guy? No, they don't.
And that's why these photos there,
it's not like that typical
like hands in the face photo.
They just look totally serene this
moment. These two innocent, innocent,
they have no reason to expect anyone to
be out there. Right. Because you know,
before this moment there weren't Paparazzi
photographers stalking celebrities
like this. This is Eden
right here. This is Eden.
Yeah. This is before the fall.
[inaudible] Mr. Lee said right
before they published, um,
and this has sort of
become their tradition.
All of the reporters got together and
stayed in the office all night and
everybody was on pins and needles
because you know, they didn't know.
They didn't know what was gonna happen.
Are people going to be outraged or are
they gonna be totally excited about this?
They just had no idea
what was going to happen.
And you also will have no idea what's
going to happen until after the break.
Yeah.
Hey, this is mark from a story of Queens.
Radiolab is supported in part by
the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science
and technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
I'm Bessie music.
I hosted esoterical talk show in
Egypt after the Arab spring until the
government tried to throw me in jail.
So now I live in America and I
host the podcast remade in America,
presented by cafe where I interview all
kinds of outsiders from comedian Maz.
You run to journalist Maria in a
wholesale and filmmaker here in view.
And I try to use those conversations
to figure out my new country American
subscribe to remade in
America, presented by
Cafe Jad Robert Radiolab.
Back to our story from reporter
Alex Young. So when we left off,
we were talking about leaving Gu.
So you need Mr. Lee and he and his team
had just captured the first Paparazzi
moment in South Korea. They had
taken a picture of these two stars
[inaudible] the photos were
pretty dark and super grainy,
totally pop brought
style like shot in night,
probably from a zoom lens like
thousands of yards away come
[inaudible] it was hard to
tell the photographs really?
[inaudible]
so he says that they all got
together in their office.
They were just about to publish
no idea what was gonna happen.
And when we first published them,
nothing really. Really?
Yeah, seriously. Oh, come on,
I'm kidding. There was general response
[inaudible]
people went crazy. Oh my
goodness. Oh my goodness.
[inaudible] the photos went viral.
It just took the whole country [inaudible]
there wasn't an incredible amount of
web traffic down there go so
much that our servers were
breaking down. So people clicked.
Oh yeah. When it all comes down
to it, people really want to know.
At first they just, you know, they
just inundated the website, uh,
trying to look at these photos.
But then they were like, oh, oh no.
So then they rushed over to the fan
sites and four of the websites from the,
the boy band, the guy crashed, shouldn't
say [inaudible] Young's website,
which is called the mini humpy page.
It just gets flooded with comments or
his file comments about how the fence
felt. Betrayed.
People were like posting deface
pictures of her in typical, um,
sexist ways. She got the brunt of it.
This is always the way it is, right?
Just like in America, that's the way
it happens. In Korea. [inaudible] put
[inaudible], you know, when
I talked to Lehman Goo,
he was the first one to recognize
that you ain't going pylon.
And Pennzoil usually when this
kind of scandal breaks, it's the,
it's the woman who gets it
worse. Yeah. Yeah. What,
so where would the, how we do,
how did the agencies respond?
[inaudible] shock in the beginning to
tell that the companies were not prepared
because their official
statement would be like,
we've talked to the celebrity about this
or we had no idea this was going on.
And you could see that the companies
were struggling. There's actually,
you know, a couple times later on where
God, the fans got really crazy
and they would actually protest at
like their live shows or whatever. Um,
and then pretty much the next
day, like after the protest,
the idol at the center of
that scramble would just
kind of vanish. Like they would just take
a indefinite hiatus from all of their,
like promotional activities. Like you
mean like the agencies just Yank them?
I mean, yeah, that was
the suggestion. Yeah.
Did the agency say
anything about that to you?
No one would go on the record with me,
but I did talk to some people over
email and they said that, you know,
when fans react this way, they're
kind of forced to take drastic action.
So they kind of confirmed that
they were disappearing idols.
They confirmed with me that
they were uh, taking action.
But here's what ends up happening and
we'll tell you [inaudible] more than just
calling you says, you know that very
first scandal that they broke. Yeah,
they got a lot of backlash,
but it showed them
that [inaudible] worked in the foreign
media could also work in South Korea.
[inaudible] so it gave us strength
to keep experimenting. So in 2011,
Lehman Goo and like a couple
of the people from sports,
all they break off and they formed
this company called dispatch.
And then the [inaudible]
following years, 2012 2013 this
is this really important chunks
time where they just start
pumping out scandals and
getting them. Gen Docs must've done
more than 10 stories. Small and baby.
Do you want to hit list? I do
want to hit the list for stuff.
There's parks Gian,
she's dating Mr p Hora with John Young.
Then tack Jaan who gets
caught with Jessica brain
dating Kim t and you have Yuna
dating Lisa Sankey Selling
Chisholm. That was like a crazy one.
And of course we all remember Beck, Yan
and [inaudible], I don't remember. Oh,
I remember it. But according to
seek in Kim, you had so many scandals
in such a short period of time,
headlines after headlines,
headlines at such a frequent
rate, that fence became somehow
desensitized
by this news. It shook us and I'm
going to put myself in there now. Yeah,
it should go. So according
to writer Aga Park,
what you saw after this crazy
onslaught of scandals is um,
well a couple of things. So
the Paparazzi became a trend.
Something that all the crane
entertainment news started picking up.
There starts to be all these other
Paparazzi companies that come out
competitors. Exactly. Just like
dispatch, but with a different name.
But the craziest part I think is that you
start seeing celebrities tiptoeing out
and telling the truth about
their lives. Little by little,
the celebrities would get more
comfortable about revealing it themselves.
For instance, in 2012 on this talk show
[inaudible] who is a member of
this k-pop boy band, he made ways,
because he explained that
celebrities dating cards
in order to get away from
all these new Paparazzi,
they parked by the Han River
and they have their dates there
and there are parking lots where multiple
celebrities park and have their secret
dates inside the car.
This is something that people always
sort of suspected was the case,
but it was Kinda like the first time
it was just out in the open like that.
And I think that that
audience reaction is like super telling.
You can hear it in the tape
there. They're laughing.
So he's breaking the spell
and what you expect is, yeah,
what you get is casual
laughter. That's a sea change.
That's a real CJ. So this happened
in just two years. You're saying?
We probably have to say five years.
You have. It's still, I mean, that's,
see this actually does make me
think, I mean, well first of all,
it's interesting to think of Paparazzi
as liberator's in this game. Totally.
Totally. Because we used to think
of them as like scum, but, uh,
I mean if you pan out, here's
literally the thought I'm having.
Like there's a tendency,
cause we're done westerners to sort of
see what happens in places like Korea as
being very different from us.
Like culturally separate. Yeah.
With the city to hear that they change
that quickly makes me think in some way
that we're all very similar or maybe
we're all headed to the same place.
I'm like, tabloid is the great equalizer.
And maybe we were all gonna
just end up all of us in
Postcard Dashi and hell,
like literally like this is how far they
traveled in five years and literally in
another five years you will have the
Kardashian family of Korea dishes all the
time and we're making sex tapes
on their own, whatever it is.
I also thought the same thing, you
know, being from America, you were like,
Whoa, this is just inevitable. But,
um, I actually don't think so anymore.
Aga told
me a story that really changed
my mind. Uh, it was like,
it was our Watergate was our k-pop
gate. It was, it changed everything. Um,
this story, it, it revolves
around [inaudible].
You're still going to do that. This one
young female solo artist [inaudible]
she's, she's just hugely popular.
I mean,
they actually call her the Korean Beyonce
and in 2013 she was just killing it
yet by this point, Eylea
has a couple albums out.
Her youtube videos have
millions and millions of views,
but then wait a minute.
November, 2013, a bomb drops.
Oh, that's [inaudible]
what happens is this, this
guy cold calls dispatch.
Mr. Lee actually picks up and he recorded
this phone call between them and the
guy tells him I have
nude pictures of Ailey
[inaudible] yeah. That's really
tells the guy watching the video.
We need to know how you obtained these
guy says [inaudible] okay. I
received them. Okay. The Sukkot,
you want to buy this from glio
somehow [inaudible] yeah. The singer
[inaudible] the singer gave
them to you? Yes. Real. Why?
[inaudible] I was her boyfriend.
What is exactly as he asked you. So,
so he's calling dispatch to see how
much these nude photos are worth about
[inaudible] and when I was
talking to Mr. Lee about this,
he said that in that moment when he was
on the phone with [inaudible] Tinika as
a reporter, I was greedy about
the story and the information.
He said that he wanted those pictures.
But what he ended up telling the guy is,
uh, to the [inaudible] in the,
we don't want your photos.
[inaudible] and then if you keep
listening to the sound call,
you can hear him with Hello
Phil. We have that just
[inaudible]
start getting really upset with the
ex boyfriend. Like this is not right.
You're crossing a line. So to
make a long story short, um,
dispatch turns down the photos and
the photos somehow make their way to a
competitor's website.
This one American k-pop
website called all K-pop,
who is, um, pretty big.
They are probably the number one k-pop
site at that time in the world yet or
free for English speakers,
English speaker, um,
the published and they get picture
of, they're the ones who publish the,
the naked pictures, remember
if they sent it or not.
But if they did it wasn't a very
good job like you could see.
So the photos come out and what
would you expect to happen? Um,
some anger maybe a little bit and then
basically people just click on the
pictures. No, what actually happens is
instantly the entire k
pops world bands together,
black ocean style and just comes
out against all k-pop. The agencies,
they start threatening to sue.
This competitor website starts this
boycott and in just a few days the figure
was like 22,000 Twitter followers
just stopped following them.
Really their, their reputation
tanks.
It was a warning to them, you know,
don't mess with us. And so, um,
they really haven't re,
I mean I haven't really followed them in
awhile but they haven't recovered since
then.
But what I think is the most surprising
part of this is just three days after
the photos come out
[inaudible]
the night of one of South Korea's biggest
awards ceremonies called the melon
music awards
and
so yours are, you know,
scheduled for that night.
Aly was supposed to receive one of these
top 10 artists of the year awards and I
think to everyone's surprise,
she actually showed up [inaudible] go are
the top 10 in about two hours in I end
the io elite.
[inaudible] no know they call
her name and she stands up,
walks the center stage,
he goes to the presenters,
she takes a bow and she looks,
I think she looks fraught
or at least overwhelmed,
but then she faces the crowd, right?
[inaudible]
at one point her face crack and she puts
her head in her elbow and she starts
crying.
Ooh,
so the sum total and ammonia,
does she go, she says,
it really means a lot to me that you
supported me, that you believed in me.
We go to, she go, despite
everything that's going on,
[inaudible] comes home.
Nida, thank you. It's Vegas.
And then she walked off stage
for me.
The story shows that they're going to
draw a line in the sand that's different
from ours for now.
For a long time or can you say,
I mean when I asked a j
park the same question,
do you think that it's going to go the
way of the West? I mean she said no way.
I don't think it's ever
going to be that way. I know,
I mean culturally Koreans
were a little more strict and
also a, I think there's also a part
where we look at these us and we're like,
come on guys.
You know like we see them as an
example of let's not totally go there.
Okay.
Yeah.
So like the u s is a cautionary tale or
something like don't ever get to that
point guys.
And maybe this is one of those ones
where you really wonder like is there a
cultural difference that runs deep enough
that you can say [inaudible] to your,
the part of you that said, I want to
know. I want to see, I want to hear.
And I think that that ultimately there
might be a culture, I don't know,
something Paul, part of me
thinks that is as the, as the,
when it gets so easy to know the most
intimate details about anyone we'll all
give in. I know this part of me, it
just feels that way. But humans. Yeah,
I dunno. I have to go with
Robert on this one. Well, I'm,
Oh, me too. Thank you Alex. Thank you.
This piece was produced by
Matt Kielty with Alex Young,
a reported by Alex and also Brenna
Farrell. Uh, thanks to our guests,
Suki and Kim h j park,
Leslie Toboco Bako on Goo.
Sarah Wolfgang and very special thanks
to our stringer and interpreter hereon
King Joseph Kim, Jeremy Bloom,
Jian choice and the K-pop,
a super group of Korean pop who
happens to be on Alex's playlist,
Spotify playlist.
Jonathan has like K-pop pavers for
entire staff that's at radiolab.org
[inaudible] have started missy.
Hi Leslie to Mako. I was telling
him about the Radiolab credits. Hi,
this is [inaudible]. Hi,
this is John King calling.
I don't know if it's too late,
but I'll just go ahead and leave you
the who goes Radiolab is because inside
that Obama and staff include,
I'm Adler than a feral visa
cable do and he Mac EOP,
Robert Cooley? No, no sir. Selfie,
Padgett area and [inaudible] while he
was doing wheeler in January without fun.
How Xander the young [inaudible] 70 10
and my car loans [inaudible] I either
head you ain't ready to hear
the message again. That's too,
Oh, good. Good. I'm Matt
[inaudible] and this message.